il était pendant trop longtemps le seul
acteur noir à avoir remporté un oscar
lorsqu'il était sur terre sur scène ils
n'étaient pas justes n'a pas juste le
fait tomber une barrière il représentait
tout ce qui ne l'avait précédé devient
l'étincelle des règles de ce qui allait
suivre je ne serais pas ici sans lui
nous sommes honorés nous sommes bénis
d'avoir pu être inspiré par sidney
poitier à vous monsieur avec tout notre
amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ou
pas
[Musique]
ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on arrive
dix ans ses parents lui ont donné un
somnifère
dont installé dans une loge dans la cale
d'un bateau pour qu'il échappe à la
tchécoslovaquie ensuite les médecins des
très beaux films sur une île à marier il
voulut excuser une belle femme ait eu
des enfants qui ont eux aussi ont fait
des films à evans j'adore ce que tu as
fait
[Musique]
f
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce magma web bien que bien plus que sa
chevelure dorée emblématique elle
illumine et toute la pièce lorsque l
entrée et arrache un sourire à quiconque
la voyez à l'écran une véritable légende
chaque jour pendant presque 50 ans elle
se soucie avant tout des autres
qu'ils aient deux pattes ou alors qu'ils
en aient 4 comme ce petit animal ici
donc le plus beau cadeau que vous pouvez
faire à betty white et d'ouvrir votre
coeur et votre foyer adopter un chien de
sauvetage comme mc n 6 qui vient de pau
merci betty merci d'avoir été notre ami
à toutes et à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi
que ce soit des amis des membres de la
famille des pères des gens nous savons
qu'il y aura des pertes nos esprits et
nos coeurs souvent refusent d'accepter
cette perte les wind ici c'est là où
nous devons rendre hommage à leur
héritage les moments où des pays nous
ont fait plaisir et qui nous rappelle de
passer ici que nous célébrons les
lumières c'est ici que nous prononcions
leur nom c'est ici que nous
applaudissons en signe de reconnaissance
[Applaudissements]